Arquímedes fue un antiguo pensador griego,
y nos enseñó que con un punto de apoyo y las palancas adecuadas,
podemos mover el mundo.
En la lucha contra la pobreza extrema, creo que hay tres palancas poderosas
en las que podemos apoyarnos.
Esta charla trata de esas palancas, y por qué pueden hacer que la pobreza
sea una batalla que se puede ganar en nuestras vidas.
¿Qué es la pobreza extrema?
Cuando llegué a zonas rurales del este de África,
me alojé una noche con una familia de campesinos.
Eran personas maravillosas.
Me invitaron a su casa. Cantamos canciones juntos
y comimos una cena sencilla.
Me dieron una manta para dormir en el suelo.
Por la mañana, sin embargo, no había nada para comer.
Y luego a la hora de comer, vi con una cada vez mayor sensación de malestar
cómo la chica mayor de la familia cocinaba gachas como sustituto del almuerzo.
Para esa comida, cada niño bebió una taza para sobrevivir.
Y no puedo decirles cuánta vergüenza sentí
cuando me dieron una de esas tazas.
Y yo sabía que tenía que aceptar su hospitalidad.
Los niños necesitan alimentos no solo para sobrevivir,
sino también para crecer física y mentalmente.
Cada día que no comen, pierden algo de su futuro.
Entre los pobres extremos, uno de cada tres niños
tiene retraso del crecimiento permanente en la vida por no comer lo suficiente.
Cuando esto se combina con escaso acceso a la atención médica,
uno de cada 10 niños extremadamente pobres morirá antes de cumplir cinco años.
Y solo una cuarta parte de los niños completará la escuela secundaria
porque no poder pagar la matrícula.
El hambre y la pobreza extrema frena el potencial humano en todas sus formas.
Nos vemos como raza humana moral con pensamientos y sentimientos
pero hasta no resolver estos problemas para todas las personas,
no cumplimos esa norma,
porque cada persona en este planeta importa.
Este niño importa.
Estos niños son importantes.
Esta chica importa.
Vemos cosas como estas,
y nos desagradan
pero esos problemas parecen tan grandes
que no sabemos cómo adoptar medidas eficaces.
Pero recuerden a nuestro amigo Arquímedes.
La pobreza mundial tiene palancas poderosas.
Es un problema como cualquier otro.
Vivo y trabajo en el campo, y como practicante,
Creo que estos son muy problemas solucionables.
Así que durante los próximos 10 minutos,
no estaremos tristes por el estado del mundo.
Vamos a ocupar nuestros cerebros.
Vamos a involucrar nuestra pasión colectiva para resolver problemas
y averiguar cuáles son esas palancas.
Palanca Nº 1: la mayoría de los pobres del mundo son agricultores.
Piensen en lo extraordinario que es esto.
Si este cuadro representa los pobres del mundo,
más de la mitad se dedica a la agricultura como una importante fuente de ingresos.
Esto me alienta mucho.
Todas estas personas tienen una profesión.
Piensen en lo poderoso que es esto.
Si los agricultores son más productivos, entonces, más de la mitad de los pobres
ganarían más dinero y saldrían de la pobreza.
Y ahora lo mejor.
El producto de la agricultura es, por supuesto, la comida.
Por eso, cuando los agricultores son más productivos, ganan más alimentos,
y eso no solo les ayuda a sí mismos,
sino que ayuda a alimentar a comunidades saludables y economías prósperas.
Y cuando los agricultores son más productivos, reducen la presión ambiental.
Solo tenemos dos maneras para alimentar al mundo:
hacer que las explotaciones agrícolas existentes sean mucho más productivas,
o destruir la selva y la sabana para hacer más tierras de cultivo,
lo que sería desastroso para el medio ambiente.
Los agricultores son básicamente un punto de apoyo muy importante.
Cuando los agricultores son más productivos,
ganan más ingresos, salen de la pobreza,
alimentan a sus comunidades y reducen la presión ambiental del territorio.
Los agricultores se sitúan en el centro del mundo.
Y no un agricultor como éste,
sino más bien como esta señora.
La mayoría de los agricultores que conozco, son mujeres.
Miren la fuerza y la voluntad que irradia de esta mujer.
Ella es físicamente fuerte, mentalmente fuerte,
y hará lo necesario para dar una vida mejor a sus hijos.
Si ponemos el futuro de la humanidad en las manos de una persona,
entonces estaría muy contento de que sea en las manos de ella.
(Aplausos)
Solo hay un problema:
Muchos pequeños agricultores no tienen acceso
a herramientas y conocimientos básicos.
En la actualidad, guardan un poco de grano del año anterior,
lo plantan en la tierra que cultivan con una azada manual.
Son herramientas y técnicas de la edad de bronce,
y por eso, muchos agricultores siguen siendo muy pobres.
Pero hay una buena noticia, una vez más.
Palanca Nº 2:
La humanidad resolvió el problema de la pobreza agrícola hace un siglo.
Déjenme recorrer los tres factores más básicos de la agricultura.
En primer lugar, la semilla híbrida se crea al cruzar dos semillas.
Si polinizan de forma natural una variedad de alto rendimiento
junto con una variedad resistente a la sequía,
se obtiene un híbrido que hereda rasgos positivos de ambos de progenitores.
Luego, los fertilizantes convencionales, si se usan de manera responsable,
es ambientalmente sostenible.
Si se microdosifica solo una pizca de fertilizantes
a una planta más alta que yo,
se desencadena una ganancia enorme en el rendimiento.
Estos son conocidos como los insumos agrícolas.
Los insumos agrícolas deben combinarse con buenas prácticas.
Si se separan las semillas al plantarlas con grandes cantidades de compost,
multiplican sus cosechas.
Estas herramientas y prácticas probadas han más que triplicado
la productividad agrícola en las principales regiones del mundo,
sacando a masas de personas de la pobreza.
Pero no hemos entregado todavía estas cosas a todo el mundo,
particularmente al África subsahariana.
Así que, en general, esta es una noticia increíble.
La humanidad resolvió realmente la pobreza agrícola hace un siglo,
en teoría.
Pero no hemos entregado todavía estas cosas a todo el mundo.
En este siglo, la razón por la que las personas permanecen pobres
es porque tal vez vivan en lugares remotos.
No tienen acceso a estas cosas.
Por lo tanto, acabar con la pobreza es simplemente una cuestión
de entregar bienes y servicios probados a las personas.
No necesitamos ninguna genialidad en este momento.
El repartidor humilde acabará con la pobreza global en nuestra vida.
Así que estas son los tres palancas,
y la palanca más potente es simplemente la entrega.
Siempre que las empresas, los gobiernos y organizaciones no lucrativas del mundo
establezcan redes de entrega de bienes para mejorar la vida,
eliminaremos la pobreza.
Esto suena muy bien en teoría,
pero ¿qué pasa en la práctica?
¿Cómo son estas redes de distribución?
Quiero compartir el ejemplo concreto que mejor conozco,
Mi organización, One Acre Fund.
Nosotros solo servimos al agricultor,
y nuestro trabajo consiste en darle herramientas necesarias para tener éxito.
Comenzamos entregando insumos agrícolas en lugares muy rurales.
Esto puede parecer inicialmente muy difícil,
pero es bastante posible. Dejen que se lo muestre,
Compramos insumos agrícolas con el poder combinado de nuestra red de agricultores,
y las almacenamos en 20 silos de este tipo.
Luego, durante la entrega se alquilan cientos de camiones de 10 toneladas
y los enviamos allá donde los agricultores esperan en el campo.
Después, reciben pedidos individuales y se van caminando a sus granjas.
Es un poco como Amazon para los agricultores rurales.
Importante, la entrega realista también incluye financiación, una forma de pago.
Los agricultores pagan poco a poco y así cubren la mayor parte de nuestros gastos.
Y luego lo concluimos con lo relacionado con la formación.
Nuestros oficiales de campo rurales entregan práctica, formación aplicada
a los agricultores en el campo
cada dos semanas.
Dondequiera que ofrecemos nuestros servicios,
los agricultores usan estas herramientas para salir de la pobreza.
Este es una agricultora en nuestro programa, Consolata.
Vean el orgullo en su rostro.
Se ha logrado una modesta prosperidad que reo que es el derecho humano
de cada persona trabajadora en el planeta.
Hoy estoy orgulloso de decir
que servimos a unos 400 000 agricultores como Consolata.
(Aplausos)
La clave para hacerlo es la entrega escalable.
En un área determinada, contratamos un oficial de campo rural
que entrega nuestros servicios a 200 agricultores, en promedio,
con más de 1000 personas que viven en esas familias.
Hoy en día, tenemos 2000 de estos oficiales de campo rurales
creciendo muy rápidamente.
Este es nuestro ejército de entrega,
y somos una sola organización.
Hay muchas empresas, gobiernos y organizaciones no lucrativas
que tienen ejércitos de entrega al igual que este.
Y creo que nos encontramos en un momento en el tiempo
donde podemos prestar de forma colectiva servicios agrícolas a todo agricultor.
Les mostraré lo posible que es.
Este es un mapa de África subsahariana,
con un mapa de EE.UU. para la escala.
Elegí el África subsahariana por ser un territorio de entrega enorme.
Es muy desafiante.
Pero analizamos cada 80 km² en el continente,
y se vio que la mitad de los agricultores vive en solo estas regiones sombreadas.
Es un área muy pequeña en general.
Si se ponen estas cajas una al lado de la otra
dentro de un mapa de EE.UU.,
solo cubrirían el este de EE.UU.
Puede pedir una pizza en cualquier parte de este territorio
y llegará a su casa caliente, fresca y deliciosa.
Si EE.UU. puede entregar pizza para un área de este tamaño,
entonces las compañías de África, gobiernos y organizaciones no lucrativas
pueden ofrecer servicios de campo a todos sus agricultores.
Esto es posible.
Voy a concluir generalizando más allá de la agricultura.
En todos los campos del desarrollo humano,
la humanidad ya ha inventado herramientas eficaces para acabar con la pobreza.
solo tenemos que entregarlas.
Así que de nuevo, en todas las áreas del desarrollo humano
personas superinteligentes inventaron hace mucho tiempo
herramientas baratas altamente eficaces.
La humanidad está armada hasta los dientes
con soluciones simples y eficaces contra la pobreza.
Solo tenemos que entregarlos a una zona bastante pequeña.
Usando de nuevo el mapa del África subsahariana como ejemplo,
recuerden que la pobreza rural se concentra en las zonas sombreadas en azul.
La pobreza urbana está aún más concentrada en esos puntos verdes.
Una vez más, usando un mapa de EE.UU. para la escala,
lo que yo llamaría una zona de entrega altamente alcanzable.
De hecho, por primera vez en la historia humana,
tenemos gran cantidad de infraestructura de reparto a nuestra disposición.
Empresas del mundo, gobiernos y organizaciones no lucrativas
tienen ejércitos de entrega que son completamente capaces
de cubrir esta área relativamente pequeña.
Solo falta la voluntad.
Si estamos dispuestos,
cada uno de nosotros tiene un papel que desempeñar.
Primero necesitamos más gente que persiga carreras en desarrollo humano,
especialmente si vive en una nación en desarrollo.
Necesitamos más trabajadores de salud,
profesores, formadores de agricultores en primera línea.
Y vendedores de los productos para la mejora de vida.
Estas son las personas que se dedican su trabajo a hacer entregas
para mejorar la vida de los demás.
Pero también necesitamos muchas personas de soporte.
Estos son los puestos disponibles en solo mi organización.
Y somos solo uno de muchos.
Esto puede sorprender, pero no importa su especialidad técnica,
existe un puesto para Ud. en esta lucha.
Y no importa cómo es logísticamente posible acabar con la pobreza,
necesitamos muchos más recursos.
Esta es nuestra principal limitación.
Para los inversores privados, necesitamos una gran expansión de capital de riesgo,
capital privado, capital de trabajo, disponible en los mercados emergentes.
Pero también hay límites con los que se puede encontrar la empresa privada.
Las empresas privadas, a menudo, tienen dificultades
para servir de manera rentable a los pobres extremos.
Así la filantropía tiene un papel importante que jugar.
Cualquier persona puede dar, pero necesitamos más liderazgo.
Necesitamos filántropos más imaginativos
Y líderes mundiales que asuman problemas en el desarrollo humano
Y conducir a la humanidad para erradicarlos de la faz del planeta.
Si Uds. se interesan por estas ideas, echen un vistazo a este sitio web.
Necesitamos más líderes.
La humanidad ha llevado personas a la luna.
Hemos inventado superordenadores que caben en el bolsillo
y que nos conectan con cualquiera en el planeta.
Hemos corrido maratones de km a un ritmo de cinco minutos por km.
Somos gente excepcional.
Pero hemos dejado a más de mil millones de los nuestros atrás.
Hasta que cada chica como esta no tenga una oportunidad
para desarrollar su pleno potencial humano,
debemos convertirlo en una carrera verdaderamente moral y simplemente humana.
Logísticamente hablando, es muy posible
acabar con la pobreza extrema.
Solo tenemos que entregar bienes y servicios probados
a todo el mundo.
Si tenemos la voluntad, cada uno tiene un papel que desempeñar.
Despleguemos nuestro tiempo, nuestras carreras,
nuestra riqueza colectiva.
Pongamos fin a la pobreza extrema
en esta vida.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)